dans 12 mois ce terrain vague deviendra
l'un des plus grands multiplexes des
yvelines la pose de la première pierre
du futur cinéma de maurepas était
organisée ce jeudi 8 novembre en face du
village des loisirs avec mon équipe on
est évidemment très très heureux c'est
l'aboutissement de longues années de
travail pour voir enfin arriver un
cinéma à maurepas multiplex qui va
davantage en attractif évidemment le
village des loisirs la zone d'activités
on va parler de maurepas évidemment en
termes maintenant culturel assez assez
fort puisque le cinéma c'est aussi une
dimension culturelle
mais c'est aussi une grande locomotive
pour la zone le cinéma pour accueillir
près de 1700 personnes réparties dans 8
salles pour garantir une immersion
totale au spectateur l'exploitant a
décidé d'investir près de 13 millions
d'euros
il y aura des écrans qui vont prendre la
couleur de l'ambiance de l'image qu'on
prolonge l image dans la salle
et après il y aura une salle mx cadets
les fauteuils bouge il ya des éclairs
il ya de la pluie pas de l'appui les
brumisateurs de la fumée quand y aura du
brouillard
enfin voilà tout un tas de choses qui
font qu'on sera vraiment immergé dans le
film des salles dernier cri qui pourrait
attirer près de cinq cent mille
visiteurs par an selon les exploitants